[ __ ] you let's talk about your birthday
no okay yeah while we're talking about
that's the first time Kevin Smith's ever
said let's stop talking about me for a
second and talk about someone else you
know what there's your birthday gift
that's my real birthday is tomorrow
we've all been lied to I feel as [ __ ]
as you but I think if we do the show
long enough we'll go right past midnight
into my birthday that's what I'm
thinking you can literally watch me age
on stage as it happens as if I've picked
the wrong Holy Grail in the cave with
Indiana Jones I'll just I'll just turn
to dust right in front of your eyes what
would that sound like I wonder if the
penitent man the penitent man he chose
poorly
and that's the cup of a carpenter
what that's good this is the 29th
birthday yeah uh-huh 29th birthday if
I'm 29
I need to be taken to some sort of
clinic right away and a team of doctors
need to start working on me maybe you're
like a Benjamin Button 29 going the
wrong way
exactly now I'll be 54 years old
tomorrow
fuckin'-a man why are you applauding
that it's awful
now I fly home tomorrow and I get to see
my wife and kid boring and what are you
gonna do yes I'm gonna put the kid to
bed at noon just start [ __ ] my wife
just all day you should [ __ ] can I
get outta bed no shut up lock the door
if you're if you're hitting 54 you got
to work that into the day and celebrate
somehow so either [ __ ] for 54 minutes
straight well that's not gonna happen
54 seconds the guy said yeah I'm with
you sir where I'm spent
where's that Jack Daniels my only friend
54 shots maybe you don't think you've
you threw back 54 shots you'd be able to
hold out for 54 minutes whiskey dick
right there yeah yeah Jack Daniels is
whisky isn't it it'd be 54 minutes
trying to get it in good just give me a
second honey I'll just well hold it or
suck it or something I don't know anyone
for me that was a frightening look into
your relationship and you know what the
thing that I will [ __ ] it'll haunt me
and as I go to sleep tonight I'll hear
did you go and just suck it or something
dealer's choice whatever you want to do
[Music]
you